ADIN WALKER: We had the opportunity
to do a thesis, which
can be for directors
directing a production,
for actors starring
in a production.
So I'll be directing this
production of "Singin'
in the Rain" as my thesis.
This was sort of a
weird choice for us.
It was -- there was something
exciting about taking
a musical, that we actually
know more about as a film
but it exists as a musical, and
something that's so, so iconic.
How can we re-imagine it?
So it's kind of this ultimate
challenge for all of us,
which was really exciting.
Everyone knows what
the musical is.
Everyone knows it's Gene
Kelly and Donald O'Connor
and it's him with the
lampposts dancing and tapping
in the street.
That it's like,
everyone knows it.
How can we then take something
that everyone knows, everyone
remembers, and present
it in a way that's new,
but it still holds on to
the truth of that film
that is so beloved?
[MUSIC PLAYING]